So the answer is none, that we can't actually make
any words with just this rule. And the reason for that
is this is a circular definition, and it's a circular
definition because we, we can never stop. If you remember the
rules for BNF grammars, that we can start from a
starting on terminal, and we keep doing replacements. We can only
stop once we have all terminals. We are never going to get
there if this is our only rule. We can keep adding
more counters, but we can never replace the non-terminal
word. Because every time we end up with the non-terminal
word again, on the right side. So with just
this rule, we can't actually make any words. All we
can do is start from word. Now our only
choice is to replace word, with counter-word well, we only
have one rule, so our only choice is to replace
the word here with counter-word. So now we end up
with counter-counter-word, but since word is a a nonterminal, we're
never done. So we can never make any word this way.